Samantha bee does not apologize
president Trump pardons a drug
trafficker at Kim Kardashian's behest
and the molar Probie puddles and unfolds
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
well the lot to get to today I have a
bunch of announcements that I need to
make right here up top first of all our
events are happening in August they're
happening in Dallas and they are
happening in Phoenix and you should go
check out the tickets right now in
Dallas and Phoenix over at Daley
wired.com slash events the tickets are
going fast we're almost sold out I
believe it in Dallas and we are
approaching almost sold out in Phoenix
so check that out right now at Daley
wired.com slash events again the tickets
are available daily where dot-com slash
bands also we are doing a father to stay
live streams we are doing that Tuesday
June 12th 7:00 p.m. Eastern
Jeremy boring the daily where God came
will host a roundtable discussion with
me Andrew Clavin and Michael nose will
sit there and say nothing the whole time
but be paid handsomely for it we'll
discuss what fatherhood means even
though Michael isn't the father and
we'll discuss why father's matter how
fatherhood will stand up against an
increasingly male culture and if you're
a subscriber you can write questions to
us at Daley wire.com you go and you
follow you type it into the chat window
and we will pick up those questions
again that is Tuesday June 12th 7:00
p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific you can find
our special live stream on Facebook and
YouTube so make sure that you do not
miss it okay before we get to the news
first I want to say thanks to our
sponsors over at blinds.com so there's
one part of your house that you probably
haven't thought very much about but it
makes a huge difference in terms of what
your home actually looks like and that
of course is the stuff that's covering
your windows that's just the old garbage
that the person three owners ago had or
the or the apartment owner who is
renting to you has instead of that stuff
you should have really nice stuff on
your windows it really upgrades the look
of your apartment or of your home and
picking out this stuff is actually kind
of difficult which is why you need to go
over to my friends at blinds.com they
make it really easy for you if you're
not sure what you want or even where to
start go to blinds comm and you get a
free online design consultation you can
send them pictures of your home and they
send back custom recommendations from a
professional for what will work with
your color scheme furniture and specific
rooms and they'll even send you free
samples to make sure everything looks as
good in person as it does online every
order gets free shipping here's the best
part if you screw it up you miss measure
you do something wrong okay if you mess
it up blinds calm makes it right for
free they remake your blinds for free
and they made it really easy for you so
go right now to blinds calm and use
promo code Ben and for a limited time
you get 20% off everything
again that's blinds comp remote clip Ben
for 20 percent off everything the faux
wood blinds the cellular shades the
roller shades and more we've used it at
the Shapiro household and blinds comm
it's first-rate and the customer service
is just top
not 20% off everything at blinds.com
when you use promo code Bennigan's
blinds comm promo code ben rules and
restrictions do apply ok so we begin
today with samantha bee samantha bee
you'll recall just about a week ago she
got herself in hot water because she
suggested that Ivanka Trump the
president of the the president's
daughter the daughter of the President
of the United States was a feckless
c-word
why because Ivanka Trump had the
temerity the utter gall the unmitigated
sort of audacity to put up a picture of
herself with her kid and in doing so she
then had somehow offended the left
because the left was all concerned about
children being separated from their
parents at the border which is an
operation of law as ruled by the 9th
Circuit Court of Appeals so Samantha P
goes on national TV and she calls Monica
Trump affectless c-word and then she
suggests that a Monica Trump should
actually go try to have sex with her
father in order to get him to change
immigration policy which is just
wonderful excellent stuff well Samantha
bee was off for the rest of the week
after that well she was back last night
and she was gonna give her apology now
well here's the wonderful thing about
apologies from the left if you're on the
left you know that there's that old that
old movie love story where the slogan
was being in love means never having to
say you're sorry love means never having
to say you're sorry
okay well being on the Left means never
having to say you're sorry laura
ingraham had to put out like a full
apology for saying the david hog a
parkland survivor was whiny about his
college admissions and she got boycotted
for that samantha be called the daughter
of the President of the United States a
feckless c-word and suggested she should
try to dress sexy to seduce her own dad
and then she goes on TV and does a like
seven minute quasi apology that is not
apology in the slightest and of course
the media are letting her off the hook
and they're saying that she is just an
emissary of genius she is just an
emissary of goodness she's an emissary
of rightness
so here's Samantha bee who it will be
noted has not said a funny thing in
years
right the last time she was funny wasn't
she's actually just the sidekick on The
Daily Show now she's not funny at all
now she goes for what we like to call
clapped her in the business it's not
laughter it's where everybody goes right
and then there's kind of like a couple
of laughs and they're not really
laughing tomorrow like smiles and
clapping because you agree with the
person you know just like you're doing
right now at this show it's like that
except I'm not a comedian
Samantha bee is a professional comedian
okay so here's Samantha bee here's her
quasi apology that is not an apology at
all last night on TV
and of course she'll just go right back
to business because that's the way it
works if you're on the left then you get
some clapped her and people pretend that
you didn't do anything wrong
if you're on the right then we cancel
your show or we boycott you and even if
you apologize we say that is
insufficient even if you are clearly
mentally ill as a Roseanne Barr is
obviously Samantha P gets to go on with
her life like nothing happened and
lecture us in the process it's my
favorite part
it's Samantha bee lecturing me I'm not
the one who went on national television
and called someone a feckless c-word and
suggested they had incest with their own
father that wasn't me you know Samantha
bee but she's gonna lecture me and she's
gonna lecture Republicans because
Republicans who are really bad how do we
know that well because they're
Republicans that's how we know they're
bad I guess a here is the execrable
Samantha P who has I will say walked
away well I've been saying for more than
a year now that there was a running gun
battle between a series of leftist
comedians to be the least funny comedian
on the left and that included Amy
Schumer and that included Lena Dunham
and then included Trevor Noah and it
included Samantha bee but Samantha bee I
mean she is now Secretariat she's just
busting out of the pack she is it she's
eight lengths ahead nobody else is even
in camera view
here's Samantha bee doing her apology
last night you know a lot of people were
offended and angry that I used an
epithet to describe the president's
daughter and advisor last week it is a
word I have used on the show many times
hoping to reclaim it this time I used it
as an insult I crossed the line I regret
it and I do apologize for that the
problem is that many women have heard
that word at the worst moments of their
lives a lot of them don't want that word
reclaimed they want it gone
and I don't blame them I don't want to
inflict more pain on them I want this
show to be challenging and I want it to
be honest but I never intended it to
hurt anyone okay composite for a second
you never intended it to hurt anyone
every day on the show she calls someone
off on them like an awful name that I
would never use she does it every single
night on her show like all the time and
when she suggests that she's trying to
reclaim the c-word this is the same sort
of stupid logic that I hear with regard
to people who use the n-word I'm trying
to reclaim the n-word and make it a term
of empowerment why why don't you say
it's a bad word people shouldn't use it
right the n-word is such a bad word and
we're not even allowed to say the full
n-word which seems to me appropriate I
feel like the c-word is the same sort of
thing I've never
tried to reclaim the kay ward I don't go
around at Scholl and my synagogue saying
the K word to people you know it sweet
let's reclaim this this slur that's been
used against Jews for a century instead
let's talk let's say to each other man I
mean let's reclaim that thing publicly
what's up Mike a word like I wouldn't do
that because that's idiotic as I
mentioned last week I wouldn't do that
like Jess is this something you're doing
you're committed to justice Hispanic so
Jess do you run do you run around your
community calling each other the S word
I assume not that's probably not a thing
right like people don't do this on a
regular basis because it's idiotic okay
this is just an excuse that she's making
for being a nasty person who likes to
use the c-word publicly and then she
gets to claim it's all about empowerment
she continues along these lines Samantha
bee boy many men were also offended by
my use of the word I do not care about
that
that's hilarious hey distracted from
more important issues I hate that I did
something to contribute to the nightmare
of 24-hour news cycles that were all
white knuckling I should have known that
a potty mouth insult would be inherently
more interesting to them than juvenile
immigration policy I would do anything
to help those kids I hate that this
distracted from them so to them I am
also sorry okay you stop right there
okay so her real apology is that she did
something distracted from the underlying
issue that was the whole point for
making the joke okay she's a smart lady
Samantha B she knows exactly what she
was doing when she went on national TV
and suggested that a vodka Trump was a
feckless c-word she knew exactly what
was going to happen this went through
writers it went through producers it was
on the teleprompter she's reading from a
teleprompter right now she doesn't have
all the stuff memorized obviously this
is just silliness and when she says I'm
so sorry to distract I should have known
I shouldn't have contribute to the
24-hour news cycle she wanted to make
news and so she said this okay it is
that simple this is obviously more heard
attempting to make news than Roseanne
Barr tweeting something out that was
execrable that valerie jarrett like
Roseanne Barr on on Twitter is a nut job
this was scripted right this was
something that was produced so I don't
buy this excuse making at all and also
by the way this idea that I can't be
offended for use of the c-word
why not I'm offended when somebody uses
the n-word because vile uncivil
disgusting behavior is vile uncivil
disgusting behavior no matter at whom it
is directed I thought that we're
supposed to live in a society where if
you see somebody use the c-word against
some
inappropriately we're supposed to step
in and say no I thought that was a good
thing I thought I'm supposed to be
offended on behalf of people who are
being maligned I mean isn't that what
makes for a better society I guess now
the idea is that if I'm a man I can't
object if a woman uses the c-word even
if she's calling another woman the
c-word I just I don't buy that at all I
think it's it's idiotic logic but she
continues with her non-apology apology
which the media will label brave
obviously if you are worried about the
death of civility don't sweat it
I'm a comedian people who hone their
voices in basement bars while yelling
back at drunk hecklers are definitely
not Paragons of civility I am I'm really
sorry that I said that word but you know
what civility is just nice words
maybe we should all worry a little bit
more about the niceness of our actions
okay just one point you just want to
point this out for one second she says
that we should worry about the niceness
of our actions rather than the contents
of our words okay
well let's say that that's the case why
are you so pissed about everything Trump
says all the time then right this is
obviously not true why are you so angry
about what Roseanne Barr says it turns
out that words are kind of actions
sometimes that doesn't mean they're
violence it doesn't mean that they are a
kind of thing that has an impact in the
world and pretend that words are all
created equal or that whatever we say
has no impact 'silly not doesn't mean
they should be restricted it doesn't
mean that every word should be met with
any sort of action it doesn't mean any
of those things but to suggest that you
are going to make a hard divide between
stuff we say and stuff we do well I
think that applies in certain contexts
that certainly doesn't apply to Samantha
B's job whose entire job is to stand in
front of a camera and say words it's not
like she's going out there you know
handing out teddy bears at the border
Samantha B's entire job is to say words
into a camera that are written for her
on a screen that moves before her right
I mean that that is her entire job and
Chava doesn't apply this logic to
anybody on the right if I were to say
the same thing Samantha bee did she'd be
calling for my firing tomorrow because
that's what that's what people on the
Left do so this sort of double standard
is really quite absurd in every way she
concludes with with a little bit more of
this non-apology apology which the media
cheered all the way
listen I wanted to introduce you to some
exciting new additions to our show these
are our new mandatory censors who will
be with us from now on don't be jittery
guys I talk fast but you'll be fine
that's right they're the best channel
for news centers in the entire business
unfortunately this is what we have to do
from now on I know I know it's some
pretty big stuff ok so this is the new
thing is that she's gonna pretend that
she's being censored in some way
she hasn't been censored in any way TBS
is allowing her to go on there and if
she wants to say feckless see where
tomorrow they'll do that too it is worth
noting by the way that her ratings stink
Samantha B's ratings stink as well they
should because she is not good at this
job but if you look at the posters all
around town so I live in LA which means
that you see Emmy posters everywhere all
the time right you're driving around you
see how the bus stop there's an Emmy
poster for Samantha B and there is this
hilarious thing that's going on right
now or Trevor Noah has a bunch of his
Emmy posters that are up and it features
a quote from Samantha bee and then
Samantha people put her Emmy poster up
and it will feature a quote from Trevor
Noah
and then Jimmy Kimmel will put one up
and it features quotes from Samantha B
and Jimmy and Trevor Noah and they all
have quotes about each other because
they're all part of this ideological
bubble we're saying stuff like Samantha
bee says is not offensive in any way the
only people who would be offended of
course are these rubes out in the middle
of the country who still think it's bad
to say the c-word about people now again
I'm not gonna do the what about ism
thing and point out here that there are
people who said the c-word about Hillary
Clinton which I thought was wrong at the
time on its face but Samantha bee is a
who is a thought leader and that ought
to make some sort of difference it won't
according to the left-wing media okay so
I want to talk a little bit about Ben
Rhodes who is out there making some
insane claims about how your control of
information should be about how your
information that you see can be
controlled first I want to say thanks to
our sponsors over at Indo Chino so
you're never gonna look better dudes
than you do in a nice suits okay there's
a reason James Bond is always well
dressed and it's because suits look
great well endowed Chino is the world's
largest made-to-measure menswear company
and they've been featured in major
publications including GQ Forbes and
Fast Company the make suits and shirts
made to your exact measurements for a
great fit guys love the wide selection
of high quality fabrics and the option
to personalize all the details including
your lapel lining and monogram so here's
how it works
you visit a showroom and you shop online
in Indo Chino calm you pick your fabric
you choose your customizations you
submit your measurements you wait for
your custom suit to arrive in just a few
weeks it actually is really fun if you
go to the showroom we haven't
early Hills out here I went out there
and they measured me and I got to look
at all the various types of fabrics it
really feels like you're on like your
Savile Row I mean it's really really
cool and this week my listeners get any
premium injured Chino suit for just 379
bucks at Indo Chino calm when you went
for promo code Shapiro at checkout
that's three hundred seventy nine bucks
an endowed Chino calm when you enter a
promo code Shapiro at checkout that's
any premium Indo Chino suit 50% off the
regular price for made-to-measure
premium suit shipping is free Indo Chino
kaam promo code Shapiro it's gonna be
the best suit that you've ever owned my
students grab a three-piece suit with a
vest the whole thing any premium suit
for just 379 bucks and free shipping and
if it doesn't fit then they will make it
right for you so go check it out Indo
Chino comm promo code Shapiro use that
promo code Shapiro and get the special
deal let them know that we sent you okay
so meanwhile Samantha B is out there
setting the world ablaze with her
bravery Ben Rhodes it's amazing we get
so much of our information from the
media we get so much of what we see from
the media and that means that what we
see is automatically filtered and Ben
Rhodes wants that filter to be even
higher so in the aftermath of 2016 when
the Democrats were utterly stunned by
the victory of President Trump they
suggested that what needs to change is
the way that information gets to us
right the big problem is that we had
information that was not filtered by the
proper sources so Ben Rhodes a man who
as the national security adviser to the
President of the United States Barack
Obama openly said that he had created an
echo chamber for information in which he
put out false information about the
Iranian regime this guy says the
government should ensure that Facebook
feeds should be controlled by the
government I mean this is an amazing
thing what Ben Rose is about say here's
what he said on MSNBC and frankly the
government also didn't have a lot of
capacity to deal with this yeah we can't
edit people's Facebook feeds and say
that's fake news and that's not and and
what worries me today Andrea is that we
still don't have a lot of capacity and
frankly our governments probably not
doing anything to prevent this and so
the likelihood that the Russians are
going to do this again in the midterm
elections in the next presidential
election is very hot okay so he thinks
that the government should now have more
control over what it is that we can see
whether this is that we he this guy who
used the power of government to crack
down on what the American people could
see and lied about it to the effect that
now Iran a terror sponsored the greatest
terrorist bouncer on planet earth has
billions of extra dollars to pass
down in pursuit of that terrorism he
thinks the government should be in
charge of what we see the same people
who find Samantha be funny we want to
control what you see that's the bottom
line the same people who think that
Samantha B is some sort of Halcyon of
feminism that's just some sort of apex
of free speech being utilized for truth
these same people think that you ought
to not be able to see my show for
example on Facebook but amantha B's show
should be featured in fact Facebook is
starting this is a new thing they're
starting their their new watch feed
their watch feed is a bunch of shows
that Facebook helps produce and they're
all from mainstream media outlets right
Facebook is not coordinating with a
bunch of right-wing outlets and
according with Daily wire to put out a
various divert a very since sundry show
with diverse points of view they're not
doing that instead they're picking a few
mainstream outlets and they're going to
promote those mainstream outlets because
Democrats have said that they should do
so and then they wonder why we on the
right are worried about the distribution
of information we have a reason to be
worried about the distribution of
information now speaking of the
distribution of information there's a
story that's trending on Twitter that I
want to talk about briefly so there's a
story that was going around today and it
was it says no gazel out right this is
what's trending on Twitter his no gays
allowed so what's the story the story is
that there was a guy in in Tennessee who
apparently put up a sign right he put up
a sign that said no gays allowed in his
store and he put up the sign after there
is the Supreme Court ruling that said
that religious bakers no longer have to
cater to same-sex weddings or at least
this particular religious Baker does not
have to cater to a same-sex wedding and
it was reported by USA Today as though
this had just happened the owner of the
store is a guy named Jeff Amex and he
said the Lord told me to he told me to
stand it goes against my religion what I
believe I'll never accept it and then he
replaced the sign with something said we
reserve the right to refuse service to
anyone who would violate our freedom of
speech and freedom of religion and
everybody on the Left went off on this
John Fugelsang said homophobic no gays
allowed sign point up put up by
homophobic Tennessee store to show
devotion to noted non homophobe Jesus
first of all it's not that Jesus was a
homophobe per se but it's not that the
New Testament is super Pro homosexuality
I mean Romans is not particularly pro
homosexuality there there are various
places in the New Testament that
demonstrate that they are not Pro
homosexuality Peter Dow who used to work
for Helena Clinton he says Tennessee
hardware store owner puts up no gays
allowed sign and claims I'm gonna take
more persecution than them because I'm
standing for what I believe in
okay and then there's another story that
came out right and then and then he
tweeted out the story and then there was
another various tweets coming out from
people on the Left Charles blow who's
who's appropriately named over the New
York Times and he tweeted out the same
stories had boys boy gays are everywhere
probably even a ston staffer you put
that a card we're store not everyone
flies a flag Tennessee hardware store
puts up no gays allowed sign okay
there's only one problem with the story
that all these people are tweeting out
its from 2015 okay this guy put up his
sign again apparently this week but the
original sign was put up in 2015 so the
whole story here is that there's a
nutcase in Tennessee who put up with no
gays allowed sign in 2015 and then took
it down within one day and now he's put
it up again and we're supposed to
believe there's a broad swath of
Christians across the country who are no
longer going to serve gay customers
because of all of this now I'll be
honest with you I don't know one
Christian who owns a store who's not
going to serve a gay customer I know a
lot of Christians who aren't interested
in catering a same-sex wedding or being
involved with something they perceived
to be a sin but I don't know any
Christians who operate a normal business
who do a sex orientation check or sexual
orientation check at the counter I've
never seen that ever but the media are
gonna focus in on that because the media
want to push a particular narrative and
that narrative is that in the absence of
government compulsion Christians
everywhere are going to be putting up no
gays allowed signs in their stores again
this story originated three years ago
and it's the same guy doing the same
thing but we're now going to pretend
that it's something brand-new and
shocking because the media have
something to push because the media have
something that they need to that they
need to show now I'll be honest at this
originally when we reported the story we
only reported the part about 2015 that
was a mistake
on my behalf over a Daily wire it's a
mistake I made while I was reporting the
story we updated the story to correct it
and to demonstrate the guy who had put
back up the sign but it doesn't
undermine the original critique which is
that if you're going to claim that this
is happening all over the country you
can't pick the same guy who does this
every three years and then say oh my god
something brand-new is happening we see
this sort of media coverage
unfortunately across the board in
California there's a guy who's running
out here for I believe it was a state
Senate seat or the governor's seat and
he was he was a a fellow who was a
neo-nazi essentially and there was one
outlying poll that showed him at double
digits in the outlying polls and it
turned out that he won one point eight
percent of the total vote but four weeks
was non-stop coverage about how this was
the new upswing inside the Republican
Party how this person presented a
serious dire threat to the state of
America now listen I think bad people
are bad people and they ought to be
called out when they're bad people
that's fine with me but to pretend that
there is some broad conspiracy some
broad swath of people who are jumping on
board here and that all of America's
Christians are going to put up no gays
allowed signs so that all of America's
Republicans are actual secret Nazis
there's an agenda that is happening and
that's why when Ben Rhodes says things
like the government ought to control
your informational feed the same people
who are fibbing about this stuff the
same people who are exaggerating these
cases to make them into a big deal those
same people are saying that they ought
to control the flow of information that
I find utterly and completely disturbing
now speaking of things that I find
utterly and completely disturbing in
just a second I want to talk about the
Kim Kardashian pardon because I know
there's a lot of people on the right who
are very fond of this Kim Kardashian
pardon it wasn't Kim Kardashian whose
partner she didn't commit a crime
but she was involved with a pardon and I
won't explain why I find this somewhat
troubling in just a second first I want
to say thanks to our sponsors over at
helix sleep so there's nobody on the
planet just like you thank God because
who needs two of you but you should have
a mattress that is built just for you
and working with the world's leading
sleep experts helix sleep has developed
a mattress that's customized to your
specific height weight and sleep
preferences so you can have the best
sleep of your life at an unbeatable
price here's how it works you go to
helix sleep calm you fill out their two
minutes sleep quiz and they'll design
your custom mattress they can even
customize each side for you and a
partner in 2018 helix sleep has taken
customized sleep to the next level with
the helix pillow and they're all new
pillows they're fully adjustable so you
can achieve perfect comfort regardless
of sleep position or body type they use
these proprietary algorithms and they
bring you the best mattress possible it
really is awesome you know we did this
we took the helix sleep quiz essentially
and then they sent us the mattress in
the mail we unwrapped it we just put it
on the bed because it inflates right in
front of you and then we have been using
it ever since it is just fantastic helix
sleep has thousands of five-star reviews
and you get a hundred nights to try them
out so go to helix sleep calm slash Ben
right now you get up to 125 bucks toward
your mattress order that's helix sleep
calm slash Ben for up to 125 bucks off
your mattress order I mean this is
basically a luxury mattress at Nam a
luxury prices helix sleep comm slash Ben
it is so good and check it out with the
slash Ben get 125 bucks up to a hundred
twenty-five bucks off your mattress
order and let them know that we say you
okay so a lot of people are very very
excited because yesterday president from
commuted the sentence for a woman named
Alice Johnson so Alice Johnson is a 63
year old grandmother this is what you
will hear in all the headlines she's a
63 year old grandmother and as a 63 year
old grandmother she ought to have been
let out of prison here is my problem so
President Trump has been rather
inconsistent on the drug war I am
somebody who is pretty libertarian on
drugs I think that marijuana
particularly ought to be decriminalized
I don't think you should go to jail for
for smoking marijuana or dealing
marijuana I am not quite as certain
about opioids because opioids actually
rob people of their capacity to think in
a pretty spectacular way that undermines
the very basis of their republic so I'm
a little more torn on harder drugs like
opioids or for example cocaine Trump has
not been torn on any of this right Trump
has actually said in the past that he
wants the death penalty for drug dealers
here's him in a rally like a month and a
half ago talking about how he wants the
death penalty for drug dealers but if we
don't get tough on the drug dealers
we're wasting our time just remember
that we're wasting our time and that
toughness includes the death penalty so
I'm going to point out here is the
inconsistency if you want to actually
say that the drug war needs to be taken
off the table we need to change our laws
drug dealers should not go to jail for
quite as long
once he at the age of 60 we should think
about releasing whatever it is if you
want to actually make a substantive
policy change that is one thing what
actually happened yesterday is that
President Trump decided to release a
drug dealer a drug trafficker her name
is Alice Johnson and Kim Kardashian was
of course extraordinarily happy about
this she tweeted out a bunch of stuff
about Alice Johnson so grateful to
Donald Trump Jared Kushner and to
everyone who has showed compassion and
contributed countless hours to this
important moment for miss Alice Marie
Johnson her commutation is inspirational
and gives hope to so many others who are
also deserving of a second chance and
she continued along these lines she said
I hope to continue this important work
by working together with organizations
who have been fighting this fight for
much longer than I haven't deserved the
recognition and then she concluded the
phone call I just had with Alice will
forever be one of my best memories
telling her for the first time and
hearing her screams while crying
together is a moment I will never forget
okay and then there's this video going
around yesterday of Alice Johnson being
released from prison and here is what it
sounded like all right so we are going
to hear from
you see there miss Johnson being
reunited with her friends and her family
they made that trip to meet her earlier
this afternoon we heard this was going
to happen to a couple of hours or so for
some of the logistics to be worked out
but then she was released
okay so then Alice Johnson came out and
praised President Trump said thank you
to President Trump I'm gonna give you
the rest of the story in just a second I
will not disappoint the world so much
faithfully oh thank you okay so here is
the issue that I have with this the
issue that I have with this is if you
had said when President Trump was
elected that he was going to go around
pardoning drug dealers based on visits
from Kim Kardashian I think a lot of his
base would have been unhappy because he
was the tough on crime guy now again if
you want to change overall policy with
regard to the drug war I think that's
probably a very good idea the drug war
has been a giant failed that it sucked
trillions of dollars from the American
economy I'm fine with that but the
notion that President Trump is now going
to be granting pardons like he would on
the apprentice that now we're gonna have
the pardon show and that's basically
what it's become some nights on Fox
where you have George papadopolis his
wife going on Fox News and begging
President Trump for pardon and you have
Rod Blagojevich's wife going on Fox News
and begging President Trump for a pardon
and now it becomes The Apprentice where
Trump just sits there at the end of a
table and instead of firing people he
pardons people I'm not a big fan of this
I don't like celebrity mergers with
politics
okay president here's the problem okay
Alice Johnson maybe she's a good
candidate for a lease but I'm not sure
why she's a specifically good candidate
for a lease she's a 63 year old woman
okay she aged right there happened she
they say she's a grandmother right that
tends to happen when you have kids when
you go to jail you become a grandmother
okay being a grandmother is not a status
you control being old is not a status
you control now she's been on a good
behavior maybe she should be paroled
there's no parole in the federal system
maybe that needs to change right maybe
there should be changes to the actual
criminal justice system maybe there
should be criminal justice reform but
that's not the same thing
as president Trump basically saying on
the one hand let's strengthen the drug
war and on the other hand saying let's
let a drug trafficker out of prison by
the way this idea that she was uniquely
innocent or something is just insane she
was sentenced in 1996 to life in prison
why because she was leading a
multi-million dollar cocaine ring
trafficking in 2002 3,000 kilograms in
involvement with the deadly Colombian
Cali drug cartel the judge in that case
who now by the way sits on the Sixth
Circuit Court of Appeals and was
confirmed to that seat by 95 to nothing
vote in the Senate called Johnson quote
the quintessential entrepreneur cocaine
trafficking ends with dead people on
both ends of the business so we don't
know how many people died because this
woman trafficked in 2002 3,000 kilograms
of cocaine but here's how all of this
started
Mike comm made a video about her and
they said does this grand mother deserve
a life sentence and then they didn't
really talk about her crime and Johnson
told her story to CNN she said after
almost two decades together in a
tumultuous relationship my husband and I
divorced in 1989 it was during this time
that my life began to spiral out of
control I lost my job and then my young
youngest son was tragically killed in a
motorcycle accident no mother should
have to bury her child the weight was
unbelievable it was a burden I couldn't
sustain I made some very poor decisions
out of desperation I want to make this
part of clear I acknowledge I have done
wrong I made the biggest mistake of my
life to make ends meet and got involved
with people selling drugs well she
didn't get involved with people selling
drugs she was the quintessential
entrepreneur running the drugs hey you
didn't get it wasn't like some sort of
accident so all this talk about she has
accepted her guilt and all the rest of
it again maybe let her out because she's
old and she writes plays and she's not
likely to go back to drug dealing after
all of this but if you're going to make
the case that you need to be harsher on
drug penalties then I'm not sure how you
make that case simultaneous with oh she
was a victim she wasn't the victim she
got involved in drug dealing herself
that was it she's a sentient human being
and if you want to change the sand or
change the standard but don't change it
just because Kim Kardashian showed up
and this is a bigger issue okay I think
right now we are in the midst of
something that I think is is deeply
stupid and that is treating our
celebrities like politicians you know in
some cases maybe that's ended up as a
good thing right president Trump has has
done some good things as president of
the United States but right now we are
ignoring actual missin necessity for
expertise in politics on behalf of
people who are famous so it's not that
President Trump met with a bunch of
criminal justice reform advocates and
then decided based on the weight of the
evidence there was time to release Alice
Johnson and restructure criminal justice
reform instead it was Kim Kardashian
came to the White House he'd sim come
he'd seen him Kim Kardashian maybe in a
sex tape or something and then he
decided you know it'd be great is I will
let her I will let her pick the next
person that I pardon so there was that
and then we also had this week the whole
hub up with the Philadelphia Eagles
and Steph Curry and LeBron James talking
about politics and then we had that
story that I discussed a couple of days
ago that Medicare and Social Security
are gonna bankrupt in the next 15 years
which one of those stories got the least
attention obviously it's the one about
Social Security but that there's a
reason for that it's because human
beings are pre-programmed to have an
addiction to celebrity we care about
what celebrities think this is how we
work I'll explain in a second the
science behind all of this and why we as
rational human beings need to buck our
addiction to celebrity because gonna
have some real ramifications for our
politics first I just want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at legacy box
so the best Father's Day gift that you
can get someone I really believe this is
to preserve their memories I mean if you
want to if you want to make your parents
happy if you want to make yourself happy
preserving your memories is the way to
do this and the best way to do this is
you need to go into the garage you need
to look at all those films that you got
out there all the VHS tapes and the old
audio tapes and a little camcorder tapes
they're just rotting out there okay and
the bugs are gonna get to him or there's
gonna be a flood you're gonna have to
run you're not gonna take those with you
and the memories are gone this is why
you need legacy box legacy box is a
simple affordable way to get your
recorded moments digitally preserved on
DVD or thumb drive so here's how it
works you go to legacy box comm and then
they send you a box and you load the
legacy box with your old tapes your
films your pictures your audio
recordings and you send it back to them
and then you get them back in a couple
of weeks on DVD or a convenient thumb
drive they're ready to watch share and
relive legacy box take care takes care
of everything and they provides they
provide updates and every step of the
process so I've done legacy box with my
parents films and everything comes back
on that thumb drive of that DVD and
finally our gonna watch that stuff and
all the stuff you thought it was gonna
be imperative for you to watch you know
back when you filmed it you can actually
see it now all right in legacy box take
care it takes care of all of it for you
go to legacy box comm slash Ben and for
my promo clip Ben and get a 40% discount
under order that's legacy box comm slash
pen again legacy box comm slash man I
can't think of a more important gift you
can give to somebody
legacy box comm slash Ben use that slash
pen and you get 40% discount on your
order and that's it's already affordable
price so go to legacy box comm slash pen
and check it out okay so in just a
second i'ma give you all the science on
why we worship celebrities first you're
gonna have to go over to daily wire comm
for $9.99 a month you can get the rest
of this show live there are some clayvin
show live there are some michael
Knowles's show live and be part of our
mailbag tomorrow when we do our Father's
Day event which we're gonna be doing
next week and you want to ask questions
your subscriptions mean that you
actually get to see you actually get to
ask us those
questions and if you want the annual
subscription then you get this the very
finest in all beverage vessels its $99 a
year so it's cheaper than the monthly
and you get this leftist here's hot or
cold tumbler which is just beloved by
all who who gaze upon it so go check
that out also breaking news
you probably heard by now that the ben
shapiro show is available on amazon
alexa and google home so if you have a
virtual assistant you can listen to my
podcast with a simple voice command
after to enable the skill on alexa or
ask google to talk to the show so for
more information just go check out our
pin and twitter okay all of this is
available if you subscribe at daily wire
and if you just want to listen to the
show later go over to itunes or youtube
we have a great Sunday special coming
out this Sunday with jonah goldberg we
have those coming out every sunday now
and they are just i think a lot of fun
we've had on Joe Rogan and we've had on
Jordan Peterson and on dr. Drew and and
now obviously we're about to have an
eternal goal Brooks we have just a great
lineup of folks who have been on the
show you're gonna want to go check Dave
Rubin you don't go on and check it out
so subscribe at YouTube or iTunes you
won't regret it
we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
so what makes us better human being so
it makes us better citizens is
overcoming our own inherent biases right
we are born of certain biases our brains
are not completely plastic we are born
with certain biases babies already
discriminate against out-groups
babies tend to be violent right wewe
have to as we become older and more
rational use our rational capacity to
overcome those instinctive biases that
we have when one of those instincts that
we've not paid a lot of attention to but
we really ought to pay attention to is
our worship of celebrity it makes sense
right if you're in a small group
there are dominance hierarchies as
jordan peterson would put it dominance
hierarchies in smaller groups dominance
hierarchies just means somebody's the
winner and somebody's the loser and
Stern the animal kingdom it's true among
human beings there's always somebody at
the top of the food chain and because we
were evolved to live in these small
groups that means that we look at the
person at the top of the dominance
hierarchy and we pay special attention
to them because when they give cues then
that may allow us more survival
mechanisms if that if we are nice to the
person at the top of dominance hierarchy
if we imitate the person at the top of
the dominance hierarchy if we pay
attention to the person at the top of
the dominance hierarchy well now take
that small scale social group and expand
that out to 300 million people the
dominance hierarchy still exists but the
way that we judge dominance is fame and
fortune right wealth and and being
famous that's how we judge who's at the
top of the dominance hierarchy and so
without us even really understanding us
understanding it we have essentially
this vestigial vestigial evolutionary
overhang where we still care what people
at the top of the so-called dominance
hierarchy think and Men and we're and
all of these things because we're
evolved to do that at small group level
and now we do it a large group level
even though Kim Kardashian has no actual
impact on our lives even though LeBron
James and Steph Curry have no actual
impact on our lives I mean this is not
me suggesting this this is evolutionary
psychologist Daniel Kruger at University
of Michigan
well now that addiction to the celebrity
has infected our politics because yep
there's another bias that human beings
suffer from so we suffer from a bias
toward celebrity a bias toward the
person at the top of the dominance
hierarchy and then there's something
called the halo effect the halo effect
is if I see somebody beautiful I also
tend to think that person is smart if I
see somebody beautiful I think that
person is nice if I think that / if I
see somebody rich that person must be
nice and also better looking right this
is just the way the human brain works we
tend to attribute all good qualities to
one person to whom we have attributed
one good quality so I mean look at celeb
we think oh they must know things but
the line from fiddler on the roof is
when you're rich they think you really
know well it's basically correct when
people are very wealthy I want to go our
very famous we tend to think they know
what they're talking about and that
holds true even when it's pretty obvious
they don't actually know what they're
talking about as we take Samantha be
seriously even though she doesn't know
what she's talking about and we'd treat
roseanne barr as though she's a
political tribal leader even though
Roseanne Barr doesn't know anything
about politics and is extraordinarily
volatile with a history of mental
illness well president Trump is in is
sort of a beneficiary of our worship of
celebrity and maybe that's had some good
impacts in terms of policy but it is not
good policy making the reason being that
in the end when you're making policy for
330 million people when you're trying to
determine the best policy with the
fewest trade-offs well you actually need
our people who have studied these issues
and when you're talking about crucial
issues like bankruptcy and Social
Security or Medicare or Medicaid going
to Kim Kardashian for this stuff is not
the right way to do it and the same
thing holds true on criminal justice
reform I'm very interested to hear what
people who have studied criminal justice
reform from right and left have said
about this stuff I'm interested to hear
what Heather McDonald has had to say
about this sort of issue I'm interested
to hear what some of the experts who've
been put forward by the Trump
administration in favor of criminal
justice reform have to hear about the I
have to say about the issue I think
they're good debates to be had about
these issues I don't think that those
debates can be had at the level of Kim
Kardashian's said we ought to let a drug
trafficker out of prison I don't think
that's the way that politics ought to be
done but if we pay attention to experts
that's more boring it's more in
fulfilling here's what's what's really
interesting about the way our government
works right now on the one level it is a
celebrity government where we care about
the president inviting the Philadelphia
Eagles to the White House and on another
level we pay no attention to the actual
experts the actual experts are the
quote-unquote bureaucrats or inside the
executive branch who don't elect her to
select that was not the way the founders
envisioned this stuff the way the
founders envisioned this stuff is the
experts were the legislators that we
elect we elected the experts those were
the people whom we were supposed to pay
attention to those were the people who
are supposed to be answerable to us so
now we've got the boat the worst of both
worlds
we've got celebrities who we don't elect
who are influencing people that we do
elect who aren't paying attention to the
experts and we have experts that we
don't elect then we're not engaging in
debate with so what we have is experts
completely disconnected from the public
celebrities completely disconnected from
the public and the only people who are
connected to the public are then kicking
the ball
- either celebrities or the experts none
of this is good for the way that the
country works now you may like the Alice
Johnson the Alice Johnson pardon that's
fine I'm not like freaking out it's not
a pardon it's a commutation I'm not
freaking out about it I don't think it's
the worst thing that ever happened I
don't think it's the end of the world by
any stretch of the imagination but I do
not like the I do not like the the basic
notion here that we should spend all of
our time paying attention to what
celebrities think I think it just makes
for bad policy now speaking of that the
the US Senate has is considering right
now the possibility of scaling back the
White House's capacity to put tariffs on
foreign products I think this is about
time I think it's beyond time senator
bob Corker who really is not a fan of
the president the president is not a fan
of his he's put forward a bill to
curtail presidential power on trade
apparently Trump called him and a
lengthy call and told him to lay off the
legislation and then corker said that he
was going to move forward with the
legislation anyway as a general rule I
think the Legislature should be in
charge of tariffs it's not the job of
the President of the United States to
unilaterally decide misusing federal
statutory law when we ought to be
putting taxes on our own citizens
tariffs are a tax if you tax products
coming from China you are forcing
Americans to pay more for that product
than her China that much it hurts the
United States a lot the fact is that it
hurts China and the sense China can't
ship products to us but it hurts the
American consumer - it's a tax on the
American consumer now if you're using
tariffs in order to ratchet down Chinese
tariffs on American products that's one
thing if you're doing it just because
you like tariffs and you think it makes
America more competitive and trade wars
are easy to win as the president has
suggested that is in another thing
entirely again just because President
Trump is the president doesn't mean he
knows what he's talking about when it
comes to trade policy this should be
kicked back to the Senate the fact that
Republican senators are shying away from
this shows their absolute cowardice on
these issues this was a senatorial
prerogative this is not a presidential
prerogative I would be saying this no
matter who is president of the United
States in any circumstance okay so in
just a second I want to give you the
update on them on the Moller Pro because
there are a couple of updates that are
worth noting here so let's begin with an
update on James Comey so James Comey who
is just a self-serving self-aggrandizing
human being I've been very critical of
James Comey I think he ought have been
fired by Obama
I thought he ought have been fired by
Trump before Trump even came into office
I said so at the time well now according
to ABC News the Justice Department's
internal watchdog has concluded that
James coming to fight authority at times
during his tenure as FBI director
according to sources familiar with the
draft report of the matter shocked him
one source told ABC News that the draft
report explicitly used the word
insubordinate to describe Cummings
behavior
another source agreed with that
characterization but could not confirm
the use of the term in the draft report
inspector general Michael Horowitz who
is an apolitical body like the IG the
Aichi's portion of the DOJ is not
supposed to be political also rebukes a
former attorney general Loretta Lynch
for her handling of the federal
investigation into Hillary Clinton's
personal email server according to
sources on Tuesday morning president
Trump complained of numerous delays in
the release of Horowitz his final report
which is expected to run several hundred
pages long and be released in the coming
days the sources who spoke to ABC News
were willing or able to address only a
portion of the draft reports complete
findings what is taking so long with the
inspector general's report on crooked
Hillary and slippery James Comey Trump
said on Twitter hope report is not being
changed and made weaker well there's no
indication that the president has seen
or will see a draft of the report before
it's released but Horowitz could
theoretically revise the report before
it is released I'll be obviously very
curious to see what the IG report says
I'm of the opinion that Comey was a
terrible terrible head of the FBI I
don't find any of this particularly
shocking you know with all of that said
the the fact is that you know well the
facts will come out I want the facts to
come in I mean while President Trump is
very angry shows a lot of the right wing
over robert muller because robert muller
apparently wants to view encrypted
messages so according to CNBC comm
special counsel robert Muller's team is
requesting that witnesses turn in their
personal phones to inspect their
encrypted messaging programs and
potentially view conversations between
associates linked to president donald
trump these these witnesses are
cooperating because Muller does in fact
have the subpoena power mowers team has
been asking witnesses and the Russia
probe to turn over phones for agents to
examine private conversations on these
various encrypted apps one of the
reasons for this might be the Paul
Manafort supposedly used encrypted apps
in order to supposedly tamper with
potential witnesses maybe that's what
Muller is looking for but this has got
people all hot and bothered because the
more Muller digs the more people on the
right are getting angry about it sean
hannity was very upset about it last
night he was saying the witnesses listen
when I use bash he's saying
sarcastically obviously
Sean says why use basher phones of the
hammer Hillary got away with it I don't
know if I advised them to follow Hillary
Clinton's lead delete all your emails
and then acid-wash the emails and hard
drives on the on the new phones then
take your phones and bash them with a
hammer into little itsy-bitsy pieces use
bleach bit remove the SIM cards and then
take the pieces and hand it over to
robert muller and say Hillary Rodham
Clinton Clinton this is equal justice
under the law okay so you know people
are saying well Sean should now be
indicted he's encouraging people to
destroy evidence
obviously sean is being sarcastic he's
pointing out the double standard that
exists between the Muller investigation
and the Hillary investigation I agree
with that double standard by the way I
think that the the Hillary investigation
was absolutely botched I think that it
was purposefully botched by the FBI I
think if you want to talk corruption in
the FBI we should worry a lot less about
Spygate until more evidence comes out we
should worry a lot more about Hillary
Clinton we should worry a lot more about
the fact that the FBI was acting to
essentially cover for Hillary Clinton
when she was destroying emails knowing
that they were classified right like
that
I don't think Sean is wrong about all of
that but I do not appreciate the double
standard I don't think just because
Hillary was corrupt that means that
other people should be corrupt also also
right now the spy gate is running into
some serious resistance from people who
have actually seen the documents now one
of the things that's been really funny
about this a lot of people in the media
who are most exercised about so-called
spy gate are people who also have not
seen the documents right they've seen
them that same number of documents that
I have meaning everything that's been
publicly revealed but there's an open
debate and isn't much of a debate
actually inside Republican Congress over
how much of spy gate is real president
Trump think spy gate is real but we now
have Devin Nunez who suggested that at
best maybe it's real but he hasn't seen
all the documents yet so he doesn't
really know we've seen it we've seen on
trey gowdy say that spy gate may not in
fact be real and we've seen speaker Ryan
say that spy gate may not in fact be
real so all I've said about spy gate
remains as soon as the evidence comes
out happy to jump on board and so the
evidence comes out not gonna jump on
board
with that said I would like to see
somebody exercise like well somebody
explain to Robert Mullen what the scope
of this investigation is or can we at
least publicly find out what the scope
of the investigation is I think that
would be helpful because like everybody
else I'm getting kind of tired of this
nonsense okay so time for some stuff I
like and then some things that I hate so
things that I like as I mentioned a
couple of weeks ago I watched this year
from stars the white queen which is
really entertaining all about the War of
the Roses the very end of the War of the
Roses and there's a good book on
everything leading up to the War of the
Roses for several centuries by Dan Jones
called the Plantagenet so if you're
interested in British history and you
really like this stuff Dan Jones his
book the Plantagenet is well worth
reading the warrior kings and queens who
made England he also wrote a book on the
War of the Roses Dan Jones very
interesting very good writer so you
should check that out if you're into
reading history so that's that's worth
seeing okay time for a couple of things
that I hate okay so we begin with oceans
eight to oceans eight is going to come
out soon is the assumption and the and
the reviews are coming in and it is
amazing to see the political bias in the
reviews the political bias in the
reviews is astonishing because when you
actually read what people are saying
about it they are trying so hard not to
say this is a bad movie it's exactly the
same as Lady Ghostbusters instead of
them just saying yeah movie kind of
stunk they're trying so it's gotta be
feminist cuz filled with women and right
there women who are now - it's not
Ocean's eleven which was men Nance
ocean's 8 which is women and so that
means then it has to be good even if
it's bad so here are some of the reviews
hey Lia Greenblatt in Entertainment
Weekly writes ocean eights girls just
want to have grand larceny can't concede
is kind of starry high glass goof that
summer movie season was made for even a
feel even if it feels lightweight by the
already zero gravity standards of the
genre so what she's really saying at the
end there is um it's kind of bad and
it's kind of fluffy but you know the
girls just wonder how grand larceny
conceit is it's it's what movies were
made for so the idea that movies really
good movie make kind of suck but the
idea of the movie is really really good
here's the Guardians Benjamin Lee
remember all these people are on the
left while great care has been taken in
populating the film with infinitely
talented performers there's been less
attention page the prose behind the
scenes
Ocean's eleven glided through its many
sharp set pieces ocean eights and
elegantly plods the smoothness of
Soderbergh's concoction often smug yet
mostly rather charming has been replaced
with a bland in personality and the work
of disinterested hired hand snappy
playful camerawork and a deft David
Holmes score are sorely missed as Ross
fills his film with plainly shot
montages of superficial luxury that
failed to feel quite as sumptuous as
they should since a nice way of saying
this movie is deathly boring and poorly
shot and then there's Manohla Dargis of
the New York Times so she credits the
ensemble cast with keeping the picture
afloat she says that Anne Hathaway is
comedy gold and she says that the end
she has fizz and delectable timing but
she says the movie kind of sucks I mean
this is the thing like all of these
reviews are basically the same they're
all basically the same and all of the
views but like here's variety oceans 8
is a casually winning heist movie no
more no less
but like countless films devoted to the
exploits of cool male criminals and
lingers most and not just for 8 year
olds has a proudly scurrilous gallery of
role models so in other words because
it's it's women it's important right
it's important it's more important than
Ocean's eleven was Ocean's eleven wasn't
very important cuz it I'd meant oceans 8
is very important because women can be
robbers too women can be high-class
thieves too now you may think to
yourself well haven't there been movies
made about female thieves in the past it
wasn't there a movie called Clute about
a female thief with Jane Fonda like all
the way back in the 1970s in which I
believe she was nominated for a Best
Supporting Actress Oscar I think she won
actually haven't there been films
featuring like Anne Hathaway as a
criminal like in Dark Knight Rises where
she actually plays Catwoman haven't
there been films with women who play who
play robbers the answer is yes there
have been lots of them
Fellman Louise I mean like there have
been lots of movies about this but know
this VIP it's very important in just the
same way the Black Panther was very
important I'm not saying Black Panther I
thought was a good movie I enjoyed the
movie but there's this this sort of
clarion call that went out from the tops
of Hollywood that this is now an
important movie capital I important
movie and that means that if the movies
good it's fantastic it's the best movie
that everyone was made and if the movie
is mediocre then it's good and Familia
movie sucked and it was mediocre it's an
affirmative action for important movies
well I love this the rap the right
people have been hired and everyone is
where they're supposed to be that level
of planning makes the heist in ocean's
hate run fairly smoothly as for the film
itself similarly curated with care it
gets the job done without ever being one
for the record books so basically this
is really boring right like all of these
reviews are exactly the same they're
bland leave the same it is really really
funny is Justin Chang of the Los Angeles
Times ocean's 8 has something to prove
and that determination is both its
strength and its limitation it works
hard stays on point de lifter delivers a
few nifty surprises and sometimes rises
to a thrilling pitch of excitement at
least before this story Peters out and
it's belabored third act but the movie
refuses to do is dazzle or resonate or
overstay its welcome which is another
way of saying it doesn't really linger
as eight as eights go it could stand to
be a little crazier again all of theirs
they're working so hard not to say the
movie sucks I've never
steam credits worked so hard not to say
movie sucks before usually critics revel
in writing bad reviews really like if
you're if you're a movie critic and it
gets rid of bad review it's juicy it's a
sink your teeth into how bad the movie
is you get to like pull out all the
stops and be as mean as you want to be
get to be triumph the insult comic dog
here you can have comedy gold with the
biggest Hollywood actresses on planet
earth I mean these like universal it's
like Cate Blanchett and half away they
every major actress of the modern era is
in this movie the movie stinks anyway I
mean if you can't make fun of that I
know you can make fun of it's like
making fun of the Los Angeles Lakers
back in the early 2000s when they got
Gary Payton Karl Malone Shaq and Kobe
and they somehow lost to the Detroit
Pistons right like there's there's no
way to not make fun of that there just
isn't okay other things that I hate so
Google has decided it's important to
change those emojis so this is a real
thing so there's big talk about
inclusion and diversity at Google so if
you need any evidence of Google making
this a priority may I direct your
attention to the salad emoji we've
removed the egg in Android P beta to
making this a more inclusive vegan salad
the egg was too insulting for vegans so
they removed the egg in the salad emoji
this is how you got Trump this is how
you got Trump you idiots my goodness you
know what I'm insulted by salad in
general I'm insulted by people who say
salad tastes good they're full of it
they're liars
okay anyone who says salad tastes good
and then they and then they say oh yeah
no I'm gonna forgo the bread I'm gonna
go for a salad yeah you're a liar okay
they I'm talking to you right now you if
you say oh no I love salad lies okay you
prefer salad because you don't wanna get
fat got it that's totally fine
but can we stop with the gas lighting
please okay the salad what makes the
salad good is the dressing or the cheese
or the meat or the stuff on top of the
salad nobody nobody ever has said you
know what I need a real treat tonight
give me some lettuce with a tomato on it
no one has ever said that
so I'm insulted by this emoji just
because it's salad it should be
immediately removed and instead they
should put like V gonna be nice to the
vegans put like vegan ice cream okay
like make it taste somewhat decent like
stack some sugar on it just like a sugar
cane how about that that's that's vegan
right right okay shouts okay so I guess
I went off track here salads stupid I
guess that's the point that I'm making
here sounds gross and anyone who says
differently is lying to you okay final
thing that I hate today
so a Maryland Democrat decided that it
was necessary to cut and add insulting
the president
of the united states why because this
Maryland Democrat happens to be pro-lgbt
and here is what the ad looks like I'm
rich madelene oh I'm running for
governor to deliver progressive results
and to stand up to Donald Trump here are
a few of the things I've done that
already infuriate him I protected
Planned Parenthood from the Republicans
in Congress I helped man assault weapons
in Maryland I believe in public schools
not vouchers and what's the number one
way I piss off Donald Trump and the
Republicans take that Trump okay um a
few things about this hat so number one
using children as little props take that
NRA ask the guests this have enrolled
what NRA stands for it no clue right and
then I like deep thing Trump actually is
like oh my god they kissed oh my god the
gay guys kissed Oh God
ah like you really think Donald Trump
you think we're ly Donald Trump cares
about that like deeply Donald Trump held
up a rainbow flag at one of his rallies
in 2016
do you think the Donald Trump would take
that Trump like really if you think that
part of the resistance is you effing
your husband like hey I just I'm so
confused by this like if this is really
like do what you want to do it's a free
country and like what like wow you're
gay okay that changes everything somehow
but no one explained why okay but what
like I don't find this effect like who
finds this like deeply offensive who's
like ooh take that Trump I know every
time like when I'm when I'm when I'm
when I'm in the mood with my wife I'm
not like take dad Obama but what in the
world this is a stupidest thing I've
ever seen and I love it they they're
throwing it out there like you know okay
I guess you know having sex with your
with your boyfriend or your husband's
you own the Khans I guess that's the
thing you can do I'm just confused as to
why you think Donald Trump would
possibly in a million years care about
this and be insulted by it like even
Mike Pence would not be insulted or care
about this like it's the insulting thing
honestly about the sad is the insult
that they think that I care about this
then they're like oh my God my life is
broken now because you're gay who
everything has changed you've totally
devastated me
woo
I remember there was there's a situation
when I was interviewing quick story and
then we'll and then we will part so when
I was interviewing for a law firm job
and in my Harvard Law School days so I
graduated laude from Harvard Law
School which means that you're gonna get
a job in law I had the worst interview
record of anyone in the history of
Harvard Law School so far as I'm aware
but one 4:32 in my interviews for
Harvard Law School because I had the
titles of my book on my resume
that's really not speculation in the
office of career services told me to
take it off my resume as soon as I did I
got two offers within a couple of weeks
but in any case there was one situation
in which I was interviewing at a major
American law firm major law firm they
had an outlet in Los Angeles and they do
this thing when they bring you out to
interview for your follow-up interview
and that is they fix you up with
somebody who they think will get along
with because they're trying to sell the
firm they're trying to show you that the
firm's a wonderful place to work and
that when you're working 2,200 billable
hours reviewing pagination that it's
just gonna be the best time you ever had
right which is complete nonsense anyway
so they decide you know what be great
Ben Shapiro right it's a Jewish name and
he went to Harvard Law School let's get
a couple of Jews from Harvard Law School
does hang him out to lunch okay well
first of all chances are isn't gonna go
that well because first of all I'm
Orthodox second of all I'm conservative
so or if you say Jews from Harvard Law
School that usually means like 98% of
the time radical left so the couple
these Jews from Harvard Law School take
me out to lunch and this is supposed to
be welcoming you into the intersectional
clique that will be this law firm and it
already started off weird because I said
I wanted to I could only eat kosher so
I'm happy to go to a not kosher
restaurant to have like a Coke or
something and they're like no we have to
go to a kosher place so like okay it's
nice of you there's only one kosher
place at that point in downtown Los
Angeles and it is a falafel shop in the
in like a hole in the wall so we're
sitting there in our in our expensive
suits and we're eating falafel at this
hole in the wall that is not
air-conditioned in middle of the summer
and and and it's it's a guy and it's a
girl and the guy is a radical
environmentalist and the girl is a and
the girl is in a girl band right she's
she's also an environmentalist but she
puts on her resume that she is in a girl
band it's like on her profile and
everything so what we're sitting there
and this guy reaches into his breast
pocket and he pulls out a column and he
starts reading from it to me and it's
about gay marriage and it's about why I
think that gay marriage and straight
marriage are not societally equivalent
because I don't think they are and he
starts reading this to me
and he says do you agree with this and I
said well yeah I wrote it so yeah and
then
and the girl then turns to me and she
goes well I'm a lesbian and I said so
and she was like shocked by this like
she actually thought I was gonna go oh
my god you're a lesbian this changed
everything what what you like chicks no
no oh
you exist you're a real person no you
know what I've changed everything I've
decided I am now Pro same-sex marriage
I've decided that my entire biblical
worldview is false now that I've met
someone who actually is homosexual it's
changed my entire life okay that didn't
happen obviously because that's stupid
that's stupid
do whatever you want it's a free country
no one cares but the fact that people on
the Left think that they're like owning
the cons by being gay like all right all
right this with this one floats your
boat if that's what gets you going
tonight yeah I guess that so it's a
weird pick-up line but sure I mean make
it make make your night better by by
owning by owning Trump all right all
right we'll be back here tomorrow with
much much more and hopefully less stupid
news I'm Ben Shapiro this is Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah all Vera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018